this is the forum to prove it the united
nations general assembly joe biden was
here for the first time as u s president
to restake a claim we will lead on all
the greatest challenges of our time from
covert to climate
peace and security
human dignity and human rights but we
will not go alone
that america is a leader by principle a
leader by example
the big announcement was on the big
challenge our climate a financial pledge
and a boost for prime minister johnson
as he prepares for the cop conference in
glasgow in just a few weeks
in april
i announced the united states will
double our public international
financing to help developing nations
tackle the climate crisis and today i'm
proud to announce that we'll work with
the congress to double that number again
and with our added support together with
increased private capital
and other from other donors
we'll be able to meet the goal of
mobilizing
100 billion dollars
to support climate action in developing
nations
mr biden talks of an inflection point
for the world but his own presidency has
had its own big inflection point in
recent weeks allies have questioned
american commitment reliability
leadership and its priorities over
afghanistan and more
we've ended
20 years of conflict in afghanistan
and as we close this period of
relentless war
we're opening a new era of relentless
diplomacy
of using the power
of our development aid
to invest in new ways of lifting people
up
around the world
he insisted he would continue to defend
democracy however challenging it may be
and yet afghanistan was a challenge
militarily at least too far
and there was a message too for the
great competitor china
we'll stand up for our allies and our
friends and oppose attempts
by stronger countries to dominate weaker
ones
whether through changes to territory by
force
economic coercion
technical exploitation or disinformation
but we're not seeking
say it again we are not seeking a new
cold war
clearly climate was a key theme and that
pledged to double us funding for
developing countries to help them fight
climate change well that is hugely
significant but the thrust of this
speech felt like it was about much more
than just climate change and a central
thread running through it was his desire
to re-establish america once again as a
global leader it was with the climate in
mind that boris johnson and his
delegation arrived by train into dc from
new york for his first white house visit
he comes with a boost the u.s climate
commitment and the scrapping of the u.s
travel ban this is very good news in the
sense that the united states has stepped
up to the plate with a a massive
contribution of a very substantial
contribution uh 11.2 billion dollars i
think it is
and that's a that's a very very good
start it means that we're
a long way towards the the goal that we
need to achieve
but the remain challenges are plenty the
future of afghanistan the stability of
nato the rise of china and of course
that trade deal with america mark stone
sky news at the white house